No more math mistakes when knitting
swatches and establishing gauge.
Find your gauge with the free
Knit It Now calculator.
I like to record my swatch information
on a string tag and attach
it right to my swatch.
Start by choosing inches or centimeters.
If you like, note your tension dial
number and the machine you used.
Enter the number of stitches you measured.
Enter in the measurement
in inches or centimeters.
Then enter in the number of rows
you measured and that measurement.
This tool will precisely
calculate your gauge.
If you'd like, you can
also print the results.
Learn more about swatching and gauge
in the Knit It Now classroom,
Swatching is not optional.
You can find it at knititnow.
Com/swatch.
No more math mistakes.